lay the blanket out take that pop Corner  fold and we're going to fold it down lay  them in the center of the blanket the  shoulders need to be below it or level  with it hold this arm down and we're  going to take the corner and we're going  to bring it around this shoulder I'm  going to tuck it in right there just  underneath then we're going to go to the  bottom of the swaddle and we're going to  bring it up and just put it a little bit  behind them tuck it like that and we  want to leave enough space for their  feet to be able to move then we're going  to take this other arm we're going to  tuck it down and we're going to bring  this other corner across the chest then  just pull it a little bit roll them over  put it underneath and then just tuck it  in and then you have them nice and  swaddled now when you swaddle a baby  there are some things you want to keep  in mind for safety reasons